-Our next guest
is a talented actress
who you know from her work
in films like
"Definitely, Maybe," "Hot Rod"
and "Wedding Crashers."
She stars in
and executive produced
the series "Wolf Like Me."
All episodes of season two
are streaming now on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-You take such
good care of me.
And you're funny.
And you bring me
diseased animals to eat.
You smell nice.
And you're home.
-You smell nice too.
I am done with the universe.
I love you, and that is
the only thing that matters.
The universe can go
and eat a bag of [bleep]
-That's the most romantic
thing anyone's ever said to me.
-Please welcome back to the show
Isla Fisher, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi, Isla.
-Hi!
-I'm so happy.
I've known you for a long time.
And you've been on this show
before, but not in studio.
So this is a very big night
for me
because it was
during the pandemic,
and you effectively busted me
for the massive difference
in the way we dressed
the last time we saw each other.
Um, here's a look.
And I think it wasn't...
it wasn't until you came on
that you realized,
"Oh, there's a massive gap
here."
-Yeah. I mean, I looked like
I was off to the Oscars,
and you look like you got
that shirt from J.Crew.
[ Laughter ]
-I think that's fairly accurate.
-By the way,
has anything changed?
-It really hasn't, though.
-That looks like my pajama top
from J.Crew.
-Thank you.
-And I could go maybe
to a cocktail party.
-Yeah. I mean, I will say,
like, I didn't know at the time,
but I'm like, "I think this is
me forever now."
-But by the way,
it's a good look. It suits you.
-I try to keep it casual.
Let us have a very nice time.
I don't know if you've seen
how they're dressed.
It's a [bleep] disaster.
-No, you guys are...
[ Laughter ]
-That's why the lights are down.
You can't believe it.
[ Laughter ]
One of the other tricky things
the last time we talked
is we were talking
about your show.
And one of the things
we couldn't reveal
was that you were
playing a werewolf.
-A werewolf, correct.
-That was a very important thing
not to give away.
-It was a spoiler.
It was a slow reveal.
And now we know.
-Now we can tell everybody.
-Yes, I play a werewolf.
-And this season starts
with a very gruesome scene
where a -- and I should note
this is a very funny show,
but a werewolf bursts
out of your stomach.
-Yeah.
-This was your idea.
-Yes, it was. I pitched it.
I pitched it to our creator,
the formidable
and brilliant Abe Forsythe,
and he was like, "I think it's
a really great dream sequence."
And so we had a tiny, like,
puppet of a baby werewolf
that bursts through my stomach
and sprays blood on everyone.
-That's so --
-But I just want to say,
in my defense,
the the werewolf parts
of the show are not as heavy
as they appear in these clips.
And actually, it's a love story.
And the werewolf is a metaphor
for the baggage
that we bring
into relationships.
And it's really about
Gary and Mary
and their incredible journey.
And now, of course,
the complications that come
with her being pregnant.
And will she have a werebaby
or will she have a regular baby?
And so there's a lot of comedy,
but we play it straight
and it's just such
a gem of a show,
and I'm so happy I did it
and happy to talk about it,
because it is sort of quirky
and genre-bending and cool,
and it's just like,
it's a great show.
-It's very unique.
There's nothing else like it.
You know, we were just
talking to, you know,
Clive Owen
is playing Sam Spade.
He can go back and look
at an old Humphrey Bogart.
But you playing
pregnant werewolf?
I feel like there's nothing...
-No.
-Like, you're just new ground.
Only future pregnant werewolves
will look at your work.
-Yeah. I'm probably going to
play like Cocaine Bear next.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just gonna focus on animals.
-Yeah.
-No. And I did a lot of
research, and it was quite cute
learning about werewolves.
And they have these, like,
I don't know, little rankings
where you're a beta
or an alpha or a sentinel
or you're like
a coupling pair.
And it was just --
it was just really fun.
Like, I don't do
much transformation.
There's a couple of scenes,
and that was actually,
like, the most fun
because you're doing
real physical work,
but you're also growling.
And of course, doing it
in front of my kids
just gets such a big laugh.
-You also -- I want to show
a photo of you
in your full makeup,
which again, you might be happy
that there's not too much of it
because I would imagine it takes
forever to make you look
this much like a werewolf.
Like, you're
unrecognizable there.
That could be anybody.
It's very nice
that you weren't like,
"No, just get a body double."
-No.
But you know what really sucks?
Is that, like,
when Abe pitched me the show,
I don't know
what I was thinking.
Maybe it was "Twilight."
Maybe I was like, "Whatever."
But I had a vision of, like,
me being like a sexy werewolf.
Like, I was like,
"I'm just going to have, like,
little teeny tiny teeth
and ears.
I'm just gonna, like,
purr my way in."
And then I, like, showed up
and like my character --
Like, they show
my character's breasts.
And they're, like, hairy with,
like, massive nipples and, like,
she's like, six foot and she's
this puppet that lurches.
I mean, this is her. I mean,
that's what I'm -- I mean...
-If that was what the --
-My agent would never
have allowed me
to take the job
if I knew
I was gonna look like that!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. If the werewolves had --
I'm sorry -- if the vampires had
looked like this in "Twilight,"
not a single kid
would have gone to that movie.
-No. Robert Pattinson
would not be
dating a supermodel right now.
No.
-No. Absolutely not.
This shot in Australia.
I'm wondering.
So you're from there.
-Yes.
-I would feel a real burden
if all of a sudden
there was sort of, you know,
American actors coming over
because I assume
they count on you
to give them
the full experience.
Do you love
that they were there?
-Well, I do, and I did,
and I tried,
but, like, Josh was very tricky
with the kangaroos.
He's like -- Josh Gad
is in the show with me.
He plays Gary and he's like,
"Where are the kangaroos?"
Like, "You're hiding
the kangaroos."
I'm like, "We're in Paddington,
like, having breakfast.
Like, we've got to get
a little further out
into like the Outback,"
but no, but did
he see any good creatures?
Yeah. I mean, it's Australia.
-Does it break your heart
that people show up
and they're like.
"Where are the weird animals?"
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "They're not
the waiters at the cafe."
-No, but you know what?
Actually, people come more with
"I don't want to see" because we
have like nine or eight tenths,
whatever of the scariest snakes
and spiders.
We have the -- we have all
the really bad guys.
So people don't want
those critters
and they don't want
the sharks at the beach.
And it's more like, "How can we
stay away from them?"
-Oh, that's good too.
-Yeah.
-I want to ask because I
wrote a children's book as well.
You wrote a children's book.
And my question to you is,
do your kids --
I know they're a little bit --
obviously older than mine.
Do the kids like the books
you've written?
-Love, love to such an extent
that they are on an audiobook
and everybody wants
"Marge in Charge"
or "Mazy the Movie Star,"
and it is just I --
please, God,
it's the greatest thing
that ever happened
to my life,
that my kids love my book.
It makes me want to cry.
It's like because
obviously my film --
they're never going to -- are
they going to see their d--
Borat? Bruno? I mean, not till
they're in their 50s?
-30s. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I don't know, are they
going to see "Wedding Crashers"?
Pretty sure
I gave a handjob scene.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
-It'd be so weird when your kids
are, like,
"You guys are canceled."
[ Laughter ]
"You're canceled
as our parents."
-No, I think we already cancel
ourselves daily in the house.
-Oh, that's true.
I guess just, like parents --
-You got to get
ahead of the cancellation.
-Yeah. Just like...
Yeah. They want to cancel you
out of just, like, normal
"I'm ashamed of my parents."
-So go further.
-Yeah. And you're like,
"You have no idea what we have
on DVD."
[ Laughter ]
What an honor
to have you back here.
I love seeing you.
You guys, that's Isla Fisher.
All episodes of "Wolf Like Me"
are streaming now on Peacock.
We'll be
right back with Robert Smigel.